[Music]  whether you like it or not  you're now a superhero  very good she's trying to show you no  i'm done i'm shown i did not go to law  school to become a vigilante  [Applause]  our universe is on the edge of a  precipice all right let's do this  who the hell are you  that name better not stick  because being a superhero is a trial by  fire  bruce i'm not gonna be a superhero what  else you're gonna do as a hulk  we just started a super human law  division and i want the she-hulk to be  the face of it  we do things by the book the book of the  shanty the book of american  uh lost  [Music]  premiering thursday august 18th new  marvel hero love that all united  let's do this seahawk attorney at law  original series streaming thursday  august 18th  only on disney plus  [Music]  you